[Music]
we're thinking about what special thing
we could do for this show tonight
everything about the Super Bowl at
Minneapolis and all that and and and it
came up to do a prince tribute like to
do a medley because I love to do medley
a little afraid of it at first but then
I thought you know I could do it my way
I'll do it my way I'm not trying to do
or like be friends I'm just trying to do
my own thing with today is a very
special day because we've been together
for about one year today I don't want to
get all mushy or anything but baby this
Suns for you I love you this is a
special anniversary one year ago what do
you remember what were you doing what
was I doing one year ago today I was
with Alex we were just we had just met
and you know it was good good night
what does it mean now to be able to look
back one year and see how things have
progressed it's crazy we both are so
happy about our lives right now and
where we're at professionally as well as
personally you know just things seem to
be flowing in a really beautiful way we
both have a lot of support for each
other and a lot of love for each other
and you know so much has changed in a
year in a sense for us for each of us
individually and we're just really happy
you guys seem like it's the perfect
couple the perfect blended family I mean
why not go ahead and take that next step
oh my god you guys have to rush
everything listen we do our little
one-year moment and we're really happy
with that right now
[Music]